good afternoon everyone welcome to the
second session of our afternoon my name
is Daniel Vargas I am an assistant
professor of law at fgv law school in
Rio de Janeiro and it is an honor and a
pleasure to be back should the US where
I have developed most of my graduate
studies the theme of this panel is law
and political science and the question
which has been presented to our speakers
is in summary dis how can Brazilian and
American academia collaborate in
research to foster the development of
institutions in both countries to answer
this question we have three generations
of legal scholars who have dedicated a
significant part of their life and
scholarship to understanding thinking
and researching the relationship between
Brazilian and American legal culture and
legal academia our first speaker will be
Professor Sergio gaya professor gaya is
an expert on administrative law in
regulation an area in which he has over
30 years of academic and professional
experience over the recent years
professor gaya has focused part of his
energy in contrasting the history of the
development of the American
administrative state and the Brazilian
administrative state he is the editor of
the Brazilian administrative law review
has published many books and articles on
the field he is the current Dean of fgv
law school and most importantly an alum
of Yale our second speaker will be
professor David threw back professor
Trebek is professor of law and Dean of
International Studies at the University
of wisconsin-madison
he's also a senior research fellow at
Harvard Law School he has been the legal
adviser to the US aid mission to Brazil
in the seventies and since then he has
kept a very close relationship to Brazil
and Brazilian studies professor true
book true Beck has supported and taught
many generations of young scholars who
have come to the US or who have tried to
develop their ideas in Brazil and have
started Yale and Harvard Law School's
some of his latest books include the
Brazilian legal profession in the age of
globalization and the law and
developmental state the Brazilian
experience in Latin America our third
speaker will be Professor fab yousa in
silver s.u.v
assistant professor of International
Studies and we carry professor of
Brazilian studies at the University of
Oklahoma
professor fabulous a BA in legal studies
at the University of Sao Paulo and
al-alam at Brasilia University where we
were classmates and after that he went
to finish his PhD in law at Northeastern
University as a Fulbright fellow he
holds more than 15 years of experience
at policy making and analysis in issues
of law and justice and beyond he has
served at the Ministry of Justice and at
the institute of applied economic
research so I suggest that we follow a
simpler structure in this panel maybe a
more traditional organizational method
professor Sir George ahah will speak
first for about 15 to 20 minutes
followed by Professor true back and
Fabio and after that we open for Q&A of
the public and also for an interaction
among the panelists so professor Guerra
[Music]
so good afternoon everyone its Thank You
professor then your Vargas for this
generous introduction and I'm delighted
to be in this panel with the very friend
of fgv professor David Trebek and also
professor fabulous Yuval Thank You
professor David Jackson for inviting me
to be here to this important symposium
and especially this panel discussing law
and political science ladies and
gentlemen and I'm pleased and honored to
be here today back to New Haven back to
you know Yale University where I had a
unique opportunity to develop a deep
research about the u.s. administrative
state under the supervision of Professor
Susan Rose Ackerman from Yale Law School
the 1891 Brazilian Constitution which
was model upon that of the United States
institutionalized Brazilian federalism
and the separation of powers so math of
comparative research between the
Brazilian and North America
institutionalism was and still is in my
view relevant in Brazilian
constitutional manners there are Studies
on the federalism on the separation of
powers from the presidential system and
on these checks and balances and indeed
gates tried by the US Supreme Court but
customarily relied upon with Brazilian
Supreme Court as the base of for their
arguments the same is happening in
administrative law with the movement led
by Professor Susan Rosario moon from
Yale Law School for the dissemination of
research and comparative and globe
administrative law there is an important
new field of academic studies involving
analyze of common issues in favor of
democracy including administrative
transparency
Cedar's accountability and government
regulation mostly everything is
regulated the energy is regulated the
transportation is regulated the
education is regulated everything is
regulated by the government a lot of red
tape micro regulation over-regulation so
this is very very important issue for
the kadhi Mian
and the revelation could be made by the
unitary executive by the president and
the ministers secretaries or by an
independent agency with some
characteristics created by the United
States of America so considering the
Brazilian agency model is closed very
close and was influenced by the system
of independent regulatory agents of the
United States of America it's
appropriate in my view to conduct legal
research from a comparative perspective
in this issue having gone through
several phases during its history the
long-lived American justice model is
very rich containing elements that could
contribute to the clearing up of certain
misunderstanding about the Brazilian
regulatory standard in my remarks today
I plan to highlight how the United
States of America built an intellectual
impractical ideology of regulation that
presumed needs to do right now Brazil
was living a very tough moment shackled
by systemic corruption and fraud in the
political field it's going to have a new
president in January promising a huge
privatization program so like what
happened in the New Deal reforms here
United States of America this issues is
very important to social and economic
development of the country speaking
about the USA for historical purposes
the Interstate Commerce Commission marks
the beginning of the implementation
this bureaucratic standard in the
revelation of public utilities involving
the complex rail system that went beyond
the border after states why the
Interstate Commerce Commission marked
the beginning of the stage the United
States of America had the Red Hat some
economic regulation since the mid 19th
century regarding transport by steamers
a tile that that period there is no
agency like now but there was a the
steamboat inspectors very close to the
model created in 1887 with the ICC about
this I strongly recommend the book of
professor Jerry Machado who we had the
pleasure to have a meeting today early
year law school and the book is entitled
creating the demonstrated Constitution
this terrific book is the first to look
and mistreated and administration and
administrative law in the earliest days
of the American Republic professor
Jeremy Shaw demonstrates that from the
very beginning Congress delegated vast
discretion to administrative officials
and army done with extrajudicial judge
Kotori rulemaking and enforcement
authority in the early 20th century the
progressive movement raised the agents
model against the chaotic scenario
revolving around the government at the
end of the nineteenth century the
movement spread through the middle class
located in urban areas shackled by the
corruption and fraud in the political
field
it happened United States in the
thirties the solution to these problems
was to create agencies to control
certain destroy activities that should
be decided by experts rationally and
free from parts and pressures in a
format known as spoil system the gnudi
where sap in in the 30s phase known as
the new devera several federal agencies
were created to
late transport aviation labor gas etc
consider the impact of agency decisions
on the lives of seasoned business a
statute was enacted 1946 to procedural
eyes their actions bring transparency
and guarantee from them until rights the
Administrative Procedure Act was enacted
to guide the operation of the agency's
detailing the mechanisms of action
indeed the APA provides guidelines for
the issuing of regulatory standards here
is and society participation judgment of
in vitro case and an addition parameters
for the judicial control of the acts of
the agents by the courts that we call
academia judicial review the APA is the
true Constitution after administrative
law of the federal level the u.s. model
the agents represent what is known in
brazil as the decentralized public
administration endowed with effective
managerial autonomy the actions of an
agents must comply with the details
containing its laws of creation when
there is a dispute about its action
courts examine the data in accordance
with a few standards established by the
law that granted powers to the agency
generally keeping the regulatory choice
do to do what is informally known as the
principle of deference most of the laws
of creation for agencies have vague and
open terms that the doctrine called
intelligible principles allowing the
agency flexibility and even discretion
to create its own rules and procedures
with this background in spite some
opponents the US regulation mario has
been kept since the 19th century to the
present day with the support of the
supreme court garrison a boston
university school of law professor who
took his JD at the Yale Law School
comments the
abandonment of the theer of non
delegation doctrine before the courts
claiming that even the head of texas
tube branch who might ventra question
sent delegation has no objection and I
quote the rationale for this virtually
complete abandonment of the non
delegation principle is simple the Court
believes possibly correctly that did
modern administrative state could not
function if Congress were actually
required to make a significant
percentage of definite mental policy
decisions judicial pinions candidly
acknowledged this rationale for
permitting delegations for example the
majority in Mistretta versus the United
States declared that our jurisprudence
has been driven by a practical
understanding that in our increasingly
complex society replete with
ever-changing and more technical
problems Congress simple cannot do its
job absent an ability to delegate power
under broad general directives when
faced with faced with a choice between
the Constitution and the structure of
modern governance the court has had no
difficulty making the choice contrary to
conventional wisdom neither did the
ribbon and Bush administration's neither
President Reagan nor President Bush ever
veto or opposes legislation and
expressed ground that is violated the
non delegation doctrine nor to my
knowledge did the Reagan Bush Justice
Department ever formal makes such an
objection to proposed it or actual
legislation and I quote in fact the US
Supreme Court validated
Tanner and the litigation of powers and
recognize the legality in the
accumulation of quasi-legislative quasi
executive and quasi judicial functions
presently the u.s. motivations favored
occupation
of position by ex experts public
participation transparency in procedures
and decisions with a procedural
safeguards system similar to the
judicial rescission model let's talk a
little bit about Brazil the Brazilian
agency model is like I said a partial
reproduction of an existing standard in
the United States of America the master
plan plan of the state governance reform
in nineteen it should in 1995 brought a
new model of independent regulatory
agencies in order to restructure public
administration it was implemented at a
time of the restructuring of the state's
way of intervening in the economy during
demonstration of former President
Fernando Henrique Cardoso mr. Cardozo
led a huge privatization problem at that
stage the creation of regulatory agency
was paramount first to attract private
capital especially foreign capital and
second to deal with technical issues for
decentralizing the executive power the
goal was learning some predictability
and making the agency less susceptible
to conflicts and politic political
interests typical of the routines of the
Brazilian Congress bringing novelty to
both Brazilian constitutional and
administrative law independent
regulatory agencies were created under a
special of turkey nature first headed by
a college aid body second granting
tenure for its commissioners third it
was created with administrated autonomy
and fourth they received quasi executive
quasi-legislative and quasi judicial
functions that we call adjudicatory
powers
right now Brazil has independent
regulatory commissions missions in
relevant industrial sectors live like
oil and gas industry energy electric
energy power health care transportation
and telecom the introduction of
regulatory agents brought some legal
controversies in Brazil first the
offense defense to the principle of the
separation of power second delegation of
powers from the legislative branch to an
elected commissioners third the
violation of the principle of the
unitary executive and fourth the lack of
legitimacy after commissioners of
independent agents holding fix in terms
like what happy United States the debate
is very close to what had happened in
the United States especially with after
the New Deal era with the revolution
that we were talking about professor
Daniel the Revolution of 1937 United
States looking toward this
constitutionality of the Brazilian Mario
in two cases the Supreme Court's
validated the tenure system the
normative functions we've mentioned to
the so called intelligible principles
that is a theory created the United
State academia and the decision maker
for me it's important to stress that the
Brazilian bureaucracy even with the
advent of regulatory agencies is still
different from the United States
bureaucratic system in terms of governor
ability and governance structures it's
closer but not exactly the same model
however there is no doubt that part of
the institutional design granting tenor
to the agency commissioners and
decision-making thana me
rady was influenced by the American
model indeed because of these factors an
alliance should be produced about about
what happened and has been happening in
the North America motto in the various
change stage along its over 150 years of
history especially at this moment when
big tech giants such as uber Google and
Facebook are acting like global service
providers Beyond Borders and you know
the structure created by the uber for
example is the same here
in New Haven or in Rio or in Istanbul or
in tel-aviv or every as well everywhere
so how to deal with this kind of
structure using the traditional
administrative law the law passed by the
Congress and go to the veto or not veto
by the president and then we solve the
problem that's the point and everything
is regulated that's my point how to deal
with it with the modern that the
destructor of the law or the rule of law
created 200 years ago for the America
input in the pursuit to improve the
regulator state both the positive and
negative aspect of the governance system
should be analyzed both the by Brazilian
and the American Academy for the
American Academy this question would be
interesting to research empirically how
an administrative system created to be
applied locally was absorbed in another
country with a very different culture
and economic and social conditions
otherwise some errors related to the
American system of regulatory agencies
can contribute to development of Brazil
agencies and not only in regards to the
demonstrative law it dude it would be
helpful to further research in several
areas and this event this symposium is
very important in my humble opinion to
this kind of discussion in conclusion
the studies could contribute to debates
on the Brazilian regulatory standard
aiming to improve or to identify
potential measures to be investigator
investigated in greater deepness thank
you for your time okay esoteric we're
gonna call this confessions of a
Brazilian astir I started to work on the
studies of Brazil and Brazilian law here
Yale fifty-three years ago and about the
same time I started working at MTV where
I did my first empirical research
project which was on the Brazilian
capital market and also helped to
develop an innovative legal education
reform project that led many years later
to the new law schools of one of which
Sergio is the Dean of and the others in
San Paulo thanks to the vision of Carlos
Ivonne the fgv decided to launch law
schools which it did not have until 2000
and that changed my life because I have
sort of become an informal member of
both faculties and Rio and some Paola
not a bad deal they don't pay a lot but
at least they at least I get to go to
Brazil rather regularly and and continue
working now confessions of a Brazilian
acai I have had several roles in
American academia
life that have given me an opportunity
to try to build Brazilian studies in law
and related fields so I've been a law
professor ever since 1967 and I've also
had administrative roles both here at
Yale later at the University of
Wisconsin where I was Dean of
international and area studies and was
in charge of all the area programs as
well as the global programs at the
Wisconsin for 11 years and then after I
retired from Wisconsin I became senior
research fellow at Harvard and I was
direct co-director of a program on
globalization law lawyers and emerging
economies and I'll get to that in a
minute
so in these roles I have had both
successes and failures and I think they
speak to some of the problems and the
potential of Brazil Studies in my field
which is law political economy and an
economic development so as a law
professor I failed to create a course on
Brazilian law now I wasn't alone because
there are in fact as far as I can find
not one course on Brazilian law in the
entire United States there was one at
Miami but taught by a friend of mine
Keith Rosen who also spent time at ftv
in the 60s but he's retired and hasn't
been replaced but I did manage to create
first at Yale and then later at
Wisconsin I continued a course on Law &
Development with a brazil module so we
studied law and development not just in
brazil and it wasn't it didn't require a
knowledge of Portuguese or Brazilian law
we produced information in English for
the students and that got students
because of course the course of
Brazilian law if your people don't speak
Portuguese what are you going to teach
them so that's part of the problem of
teaching Brazilian law
but tying bazzill to some other topic
like lon like development and and laws
rollin development was successful I also
have been successful in teaching
Brazilian students both in the United
States in Brazil and in mentoring and
co-authoring including with my colleague
here an article on exactly the topic he
just talked about which is the
importation of American legal
institutions into Brazil as part of the
privatization so there we come full
circle ok so that was my successes now
when I was chair of the now-defunct law
and modernization program at Yale in the
60s and early 70s we developed the idea
of a course in law and development that
came out of that program and that
allowed us to build Brazil material in
along with Indian material and Chinese
material over time of course the content
changed but we always had Brazil in
there and I was able to bring leading
with people studying Brazil from other
countries who knew about Brazil and also
Brazilian scholars and I'm very proud to
say that the Yale program in law and
modernization trained bolivar Lemonnier
and bulevar de Souza Santos both of them
were fellows in that program and went on
to become important figures in Brazil
studies various types as a Dean at
Wisconsin I failed to maintain Brazilian
studies when Tom Skidmore left Madison
now you probably don't know that his
name was mentioned this morning Tom
Skidmore was the father of all brazilian
a-- stand he was a wonderful guy and he
was a one-man brazilian Studies program
at wisconsin and he brought people and
built things around them of course
wisconsin has and as look for long had
one
the top Portuguese departments in the
country so that was a base but when he
left as dean of International Studies
the history department where he was did
not want to replace him with a Brazilian
as they wanted somebody to work on Chile
and I was incapable of doing anything
about that because like almost every
American University not everyone but
almost everyone the positions are in the
departments and if the department
doesn't want a historian in Brazil too
bad if the linic alliance decides they'd
rather do China with a slot that comes
open they do it and that is one of the
dilemmas of maintaining Brazil studies
in in American universities is the fact
that the except for a few positions in a
few schools that are earmarked for
Brazil or under the control of the
Internet what we call the senior
international officers of the university
you're at the mercy of the vagaries of
what particular departments are
interested in it and and there's
fashions and and they come and go so
that was a failure but we did create
research networks again recognizing that
the best way to get people in American
universities to get interested in Brazil
is to relate it to something else to
environment to climate change to human
rights to development to whatever and
that worked in at Wisconsin as well and
finally at Harvard where I've been the
director of this program on studying
lawyers in and I'm very proud of this
because I think this is it really a
great success we created exactly what
some of the people in the first panel
that spoke of interdisciplinary
multi-national teams doing collaborative
research in this case on the
rise of the corporate legal profession
in Brazil this was part of a three
country study there's an India study and
a Brazilian study and a China study and
here it is the Brazilian legal
profession in the age of globalization
edited by Luciana Cunha Daniela Montero
Cabaye and Jose Garces geraldi David
Trebek and David Wilkins
so the David's are Americans and
everybody else is a professor at F G V
so I think that this and we had a team
of 50 people working on this over a
five-year period research assistants
junior faculty blah blah blah blah blah
okay
so that's sort of a life's experience
all right now what what can I take of a
more general nature from this experience
so the first is I've already told you
that people don't study Brazilian law in
the United States so I did an informal
survey it's in the last couple of days
and as far as I can tell there is in
fact not one course taught in one
American law school by anybody called
Brazilian law or anything like that
there are a few law professors like
myself who read Portuguese who followed
Brazil who are interested in Brazil and
teach somehow bring Brazil into their
teaching but not in a course on
Brazilian law there's a program on a
Brazil and the environment at Pace my
colleague David Wilkins always uses
material on Brazil in his courses on the
global legal profession dan brinks at
Texas who's a lawyer and a political
scientist talks about human rights in
Brazil and there are many other things
like that but that's the way you you you
you you really can break through the
barriers the language barriers the lack
of student interest in Brazil such at
least in law these days
and so on so where do we go from here I
think that's the title of the program
I'd say yeah
ah the road ahead where is the road
ahead rocky I'm afraid but nonetheless
promising so what is the road ahead well
I think and Carlos Ivonne said when we
were chatting during the break Brazil is
at a turning point at a very very clear
it's clear that it's turning but it's
not clear where it's turning and how far
it's turning and to what so this causes
anxiety and concern in some quarters and
in others it seems that some some are
happy with the changes and some are
happy with some changes and unhappy with
others so you could be happy about the
economy and unhappy about other things
or vice-versa but the point is it is a
liminal moment in the history of this
country and it's a moment in which
Brazil is going through things which are
going on around the world and which are
great interest to people in the American
Academy things like the fate of
democracy the role of the judiciary the
future of human rights the nature of
environmental governance the ability of
law to be to protect the the environment
or not to preserve the rights of
minorities and so on so forth these are
all questions that are big questions
they're questions that in the American
Academy are important Brazil fits in
within this narrative in the sense that
it is a country that offers promise and
also despair and it seems to me the time
has come to launch a new version of
Brazil Studies in our field which would
be interdisciplinary
again one of the lessons we've learned
from our colleagues in the previous
panel would come what would be led
jointly by Brazil and us institutions
rather than being some sort of you know
US dominated institution and we're very
proud of the fact that this study was
jointly negotiated between Harvard and
FTV and would focus on important issues
interdisciplinary teams where if you
know we could recruit American scholars
who don't read or speak Portuguese but
Brazilian scholars who do read and talk
English or vice-versa we can get through
the barriers and I think that there's a
tremendous opportunity to study things
like how do you preserve democratic
institutions in a time of rapid change
what's the role of judiciary how do
electoral systems we have a little bit
of this issue at home in case you
haven't noticed and we certainly would
be able to discuss our own problems in
these areas we talked about law politics
in the environment that that was already
well covered this more in the previous
session human rights what about criminal
justice the rights of defendants free
speech minority rights and so on so
forth these are topics on which one
could develop a tremendous amount of new
interest in Brazil in the United States
and I think that we're here at a perfect
time and we've got the perfect kind of
environment I think fgv could take a
lead Carlos listen up
Yale could play a very important role
listen up because there is already a
interest at the Yale Law School in
Brazil
although the faculty hasn't engaged as
much as the students have
but after all the students you know are
what it's all about anyway and there is
a program where
Yale students spend time at F TV and
Goosby in the summers right so there's a
little and it's just a sort of thing I
have in mind and that's a little thing
you could build on and there's lots of
other places and things and and here's
the professor of Brazil Studies in
Oklahoma so we can have a a Western
southwestern branch so I think this
could be great and I hope you'll all
pick this up and run with it thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon
or should I say howdy to do justice to
the reference to the south west south
south western location it's a great
pleasure to be here at AEI University I
would like to thank the University thank
the ministry and thank UNESCO for this
this invitation it's a it's an honor
David was mentioned he used the word
Brazilian is and I tend to say that that
there are cues senses in which the word
Brazilian is is it can be used one which
i think is more of a thin sense as as a
label that people use perhaps
strategically once they're doing
research about Brazil or communicating
about Brazil but there is a thicker
sense and that is Brazilian is as an
identity and as an identity it has to
emerge from a deep rooted and collective
experience and and in that sense it's in
that sense that I use the word Brazilian
is and it's in that sense that I'm gonna
say a little bit about how I envisioned
Brazil studies in the fields of law and
political science developing toward a
road ahead so the question that has been
posed to us is how foreign the for
review of the American Academy can
contribute to or how does it contribute
to development of research on Brazilian
politics and institutions in both
countries and when I look at this
question a lot of things come to my mind
so for example why is the foreign view
of the American Academy is there a
foreign view of an America of the
American Academy about Brazilian laws
and institutions or are there multiple
views that may or may not come together
so why is the development of research
are we talking here about again and this
I guess goes back to the issue of
identity are we talking here about reefs
that's being done by PhD candidate who
learns some Portuguese goes to Brazil
interacts with some elite people and
comes back and tells a story about
Brazil or is it research that's based on
a more long-term collaborative kind of
effort why are politics and institutions
are we willing to recognize more
indigenous institutions when we go to
Brazil to research or are we looking to
find what resembles US institutions and
and then when that doesn't happen find
that problematic right because the US
would be understood as a more advanced
model of society and I you know I raise
all these questions because of the place
where I come from and where David Trebek
comes from and that is the field of law
or that the the area that we call law
and society law in society was developed
here in the US so how does the foreign
view right the weather Academy can
contribute so law and society was a
movement created here in the u.s. about
50 years ago and it it had at least in
my understanding it it had and it has
had three premises one is the study of
law in action that is not law that's in
the books but how that law gets actually
implemented how all sorts of problems
emerge when we are talking about law in
in in people's lives what kinds of
resistance is in non-compliance with the
law show up when when there happens the
second is interdisciplinary so law in
society as any other project from the
sixties emerged somehow with in in the
wake of some discontent with the status
quo and that involved the status quo
imposed by disciplines so lawyers were
not satisfied with the way law was
discussed in law schools and
sociologists were not satisfied with
legal issues will be discussed in
sociology and so on and these people
gather around what became the law and
society association to engage in that
kind of exchange beyond the bearers of
their disciplines and the third is that
law in society again because of the 60s
and the atmosphere was progressive it
was concerned with how law understood in
action can serve justice can change
society for better can can make more
relationships more equal and can promote
freedom okay so that's a that's how I'm
gonna be approaching the question and
what I'm gonna be bringing here is some
lessons that we learned by walking the
walk of law and society studies
particularly at law and development of
which David is I guess the best
expression here in the US as especially
as it relates to Brazil because of all
the work that he mentioned here that
that he did so David is someone who
comes from the same background he's
actually living it as it takes shape in
the 60s and then he has all that
experience to go into Brazil trying to
implement some development law illegal
development projects that is trying to
change or collaborate with those who
wanted to change Brazilian law to change
the Brazilian society and he writes
after he he goes through that experience
and he comes back to the US in 72 and
then in 76 with another great legal
scholar Marco Lanner they write a couple
of papers that are very enlightening
about how this project can inform
perhaps an answer to that big question
that we have so David essentially he
tells the story that when he went to
Brazil and he and Yelena went to do
legal development work they they had the
vision right so what's the foreign
vision so they had the vision that the
law was the system of
rules that are applied by general as
opposed to particularistic systems of
rules that could for example be produced
by indigenous communities or other forms
of social groups so this general rules
they are applied by specialized agencies
that is the judiciary courts or
administrative agencies in a way that's
universal and that's uniform so that's
what distinguish the rule of law from
all those particularistic legal systems
or normative systems because they are
not even given the quality of being
legal law has a purpose behind it it so
when laws are passed when the court
makes a decision there's an intent to
change society or to reinforce some
rules in that society so there's a
purpose behind law which makes law an
instrument for a variety of possible
goals law is also backed up by this
state which again differs the law from
other normative systems so when you have
this system that's universal that's
backed up by this state and that has a
purpose and you mobilize that for a
purpose
you can then produce change and that
change was in economic terms and these
scholars at the time they understood
that one role that law could play in the
Brazilian context was to help organize
markets so not very different from what
we are kind of discussing today and the
second way in which law could could
mobilize as such could could cause
change was a political right if you set
up a system of private rights and you
have independent courts applying that
system uniformly and
and universally that's going to promote
civil liberties and all good things are
going to come together so in this tube
and so that leads to a couple of
prescriptions that is when they went to
Brazil and when they went to do their
develop legal development work they were
they understood that that the task was
to produce beggar loss to improve the
application of laws and to cause some
changes in legal culture and legal
reasoning especially through reforms in
legal education so that's the you know
those are the were the topics around
which they build a research agenda and
the research agenda covered essentially
the legal needs that the legal change
that needed to be promoted for some
specific developmental goals to to be
achieved and and problems that might
exist that would make those change so
it's a it's a very normative but at the
same time scientific enterprise that
that that's actually typical of legal
studies in a way so what happens when my
colleagues went to Brazil went to India
and other countries so they met
different social economic structures in
which the states and not the market
played a more central role in which and
in which the law in turn played a
different role then the core assumptions
that they held would suggest the results
that they achieved were sometimes
unexpected and unintended so for example
David tells the story about one of the
legal education reform projects that he
worked with he worked on which later on
generated fgv law schools but at the
time because so one of the goals of the
project was to
to make lawyers think more in terms of
the purpose of the law breaking with the
formalists attitude that most Brazilians
law Brazilian lawyers have and so one of
the things that he points out is that
these lawyers who were coming out of
these programs they held now these
skills they were able to think more
purposely in terms of the law but I
actually made them not oppose the state
but but collaborate with the state which
then was becoming more and more
authoritarian that's the sixth day in
Brazil six this and and so you know all
these expectations that they had that
their reforms would cause political
change and may presume more of a liberal
oriented country were being were being
frustrated and in that sense the legal
development project helped legitimize
auto-return is at the same time they
were losing faith in us liberal legalism
this is the posts or post-vietnam era in
the United States and they were becoming
doubtful about how desirable those u.s.
model and the policy policy motives
behind their dissemination were so you
know I'm telling this story very briefly
I can refer to the two pieces that I'm
citing here and I think everybody should
read them no matter what your area is
because it raises some issues that I
think I really cross-cutting to any sort
of university collaboration between the
u.s. and Brazil but so how does the for
a view of the American Academy
contributes to answer to that I think we
have to learn from that experience and
to create an infrastructure that will
help us overcome you know all the
problems that they faced so my my point
here is that in light of all those those
those points that they raised in the
papers and that the history of this feud
tells us is that we can't and this is so
the question is how does the vision I'm
saying that I'm saying that there's a
way in which it doesn't contribute to
development right and it doesn't
contribute if it's not market by an open
commitment to freedom equality and
democracy it doesn't contribute if it's
not market by awareness of these
structural contradictions and conflicts
that constitute Brazil and where
research fits amid those and it doesn't
contribute if it's not based on
horizontal and solidary relationships
with the Brazilians there's a lot of
obstacles for this to happen in the u.s.
it takes time it's it takes energy it
takes resources it's no wonder that we
don't find many Brazil study centers
around and those who exist were recently
based on some source of funds that that
came up with Brazil's rice but we think
we can't take for granted that this is
going to continue there are no tangible
rewards Beth was mentioning that if we
do a collaborative work that helps our
tenor that's the case probably for
biological sciences for social science
that's not the case whatever paper are
published with with a Brazilian
colleague is not gonna count or is gonna
count very little to my tenor evaluation
and and all the work that I whatever
work I put into building that that kind
of infrastructure is not it's not gonna
count either I mean my contracts 44 40
40 no 45 45 10 so 10 % is my expectation
of service and you can tell how much
service it takes to build that kind of
infrastructure that we will allow for
this to happen
but there are also obstacles in Brazil
that I would like to point out too and
this goes back to the some of the
conversation that was happening here
around the environment the context in
this change that's happening in Brazil
is the signals are that funds are going
to be cut that universities are going to
be privatized that some programs that
were helping make the Brazilian
universities more inclusive and more
diverse which is extremely important for
us to be in touch with the complexity of
the Brazilian society I mean if we're
just talking to the Brazilian elites
that's not going to help us you know
build programs that are significant so
Brazilian diverses were becoming more
and more reflective of the Brazilian
complexity and I'm afraid that this is
going to go away with the current trends
and and lastly the trends of in anti
intellectualism in the attacks on
academic freedom as we see for example
in the so-called Escala same partido and
and all the controversies around a name
and the Brazilian admission exam and the
the the fact that an an asked the
question of involving you know gender
identity that was seen as part of
gender ideology that now needs to be
curbed you all know what I'm talking
about and I think it's important that we
talk about these issues here but we keep
on going we we can't a few deterred by
all these these obstacles so and and I'm
gonna finish by saying just a few words
about my own experience and and I look
at what bad did at in Florida and and
that's a that's certainly a source of
inspiration and if not a model for us I
joined last year David Boren College of
International Studies at the University
of Oklahoma and and since then in in
building on things from the past that in
work that had been done by my colleague
than Erica rob Larkins who's now in San
Diego I helped and I'm helping build a
Brazil Studies program and and there's
you know all these components that you
were seen in the program coursework we
want to train our students in in Brazil
we want to make them aware of you know
how complex Brazil is and all the issues
and tensions that characterize the
Brazilian society and give them
Portuguese foundations we do events as
your universities certainly do as well
we are establishing exchange programs we
have in the spring two visiting scholars
coming to you in one undergrad intern so
we want to bring Brazil to our campus we
are have a developing partnership with
other universities to for exchange
programs we are launching some
publications because we think that some
things about Brazil need to come to the
knowledge of us scholars very quickly
and in English I mean they we don't have
time to miss in that sense so one of the
publications we are we're launching is
called one-pager and that is we want to
have you know scholars articulating and
argue
and bringing daga about contemporary
Brazil in one single page so that we can
have a stock of knowledge about
contemporary trends in in public policy
and institutions in Brazil and there's
another project I'm Oh skip for now and
we want to move toward an institutional
research agenda I'm actually hosting a
workshop on December 14 for the whole
University whoever is interested in
doing research in Brazil or about Brazil
is welcome at oh you and and nearby
universes we have people from OSU and
from University of Tulsa coming and we
are planning to develop a research
agenda and get some grants and starts
that's kind of collaborative Network
projects and finally and this is I think
one of the things that make me very
enthusiastic about the work that I'm
doing is we have a Center in Rio we have
a Study Center a physical place where we
bring our students to we have a faculty
in residence every year at i/o Rio
I'm not going to show this video because
this is a there's a student who make a
video of his experiences in Rio and it's
fascinating but but it's a student it's
very it's very social cultural but but
so we have faculty in residence faculty
who spend an entire year in Brazil and
we hope that they will develop their
their roots in the country and make the
connections that will allow them to do
rigorous research but also contextualize
it research and we have semester long
but also short term programs those are
also open to partnerships so one thing
I'm trying to do with some universities
is to co-teach courses so you send your
faculty I send my faculty we bring your
students I bring my students are no
issues with tuition and transcripts we
teach a course together in Rio
for this bigger group of students so
that they can also interact with yet
which each other for seven or fifteen
days and and the only thing that you pay
for that is a fee for the center because
they take care of all the logistics
housing physical space etc and that's a
good I guess a good resource for us to
discuss collaboration with MTV reo as
well so sorry I don't know how much time
I spoke for I hope you didn't go well
beyond the expectations but this is this
is a real honor and I'm thankful for the
invitation and for the opportunity so we
have a couple of we have a couple of
minutes for questions and answers
thank you it is okay now I just gonna
say something about if you were watching
TV last night Brazilian TV I think you
would be not surprised just when I was
it's I'm still surprised but happy
watching after having studied law in
Brazil 40 years ago and now I watch TV
and I was watching listening to the
justice from the Supreme Court to Brazil
discussing the pardon the law that the
president would be able to pardon or not
corrupt people and this discussion and
what the justices were talking about to
my surprise and this is we are talking
about criminal law they were mentioning
things like the Federalist Papers they
were talking about the American
Constitution and the how we started all
of that and in a way it was not so
surprising because it's constitutional
law as witnesses be pointed out the
resume copied in a way they first
discussed this in 1891 and restrictive
law has been also been influenced by by
the US but criminal law when I went to
law school we were used to be used to
read Italian authors Carney Lutie and
others because this is procedure a law
that was and it's coming so what my
point is when I was listening to this
and when I listen to you all here now I
was thinking yeah whenever there is a
need that's the one the transplants come
and when the inspiration from other
countries comes to fall for our law in
Brazil in any country at the moment but
you will listen to people talking about
corruption law and so I never heard this
before in my years in in practice of law
it was you know you hear quid pro quo
yeah beyond reasonable doubt plea
bargaining all the things that America
has alone explicit compliance so these
are things that come because of the need
at the moment I'm not going to talk too
long but it but this is that among the
panelists some somebody would
you know agree or disagree what I'm
saying there was a professor and
recently a professional right from Paulo
it would say that young lawyers have
been replacing as lawyers for those
corrupt that use the corruption because
they they have study here in US and they
know something about plea bargain and
the old lawyers that have we're
representing them the corrupt those
charged with corruption before were
delay you using delaying tactics to
postpone and postpone interior get to
the statute of limitations and then they
realize well the the clients is realize
no we want the young lawyers because
they use it something much more practice
I don't want to go too much on that but
I just wonder if you you agree with some
of these thoughts that come up to my
mind where I'll listen to the different
fields of law and the need the demand
for inspiration in other countries
particularly in u.s. anyone interested
in addressing that question if you want
to get a couple if no one else has
optimized I know I have Oh help me it
was very short special ordination about
administrative law if this is a clue the
intellect well-prepared because this is
really part for us in the biometric
position interaction for the America and
vegetation so you want to know if there
is intellectual property this I know
that there is but what to do to improve
you know in our country as a scientist
when I applied for this to tell pro
telecom operators take me to three years
four years and all right someone did
something better than I did and I
lose the opportunity just talk about
thank you
third question just a quick question to
that to add to everything that's been
said
I especially two fabulous possibilities
do you think because you you lay a whole
bunch of the blame on the previous
generation of scholars trying to
implement this kind of program
so I'm asking what kind of
responsibility or in the in the process
that you as a brazilian scholar wants to
take in this in this whole scenario that
you exposed because i think the root of
the what we call mood complex is
actually not taking responsibility for
anything in blaming oh you know putting
all the blame on the other so that's my
question
i'm gonna take up the last question i
know who suggested him but it's really
about me it is it is because what he's
saying is that when you know when we
this is a this was in the 60s there was
a whole thing called law development
which was an american movement supported
largely by the ford foundation but also
by the united states government and
there were very simple ideas of what
would work what was needed the americans
came with their ideas i was one of them
we had a kind of romantic vision of our
own system thought it was much better
and worked better than it actually did
and we thought that if we reformed one
part of brazilian law then it would
naturally reform other parts so we
thought that if you strengthen the
effectiveness of law that it would
naturally also strengthen the liberal
nature of law
it would bring about political freedom
and political liberty and civil rights
and all these things we really believed
this and we you know the Brazilians
looked at us and I'm sure they said all
these guys but they were willing to take
pieces of this project and they knew
that that more you know idealistic parts
would probably wouldn't work but they
were happy to make the reforms that
needed to be made in their view and in
ours too so what I think Fabio is trying
to say I don't want to put words in his
mouth but since they were words about me
I feel a right to is that you have to
approach this from the American point of
view with with a much more open mind
with a much greater understanding of the
complexity of systems and how legal
rules and procedures are embedded in a
complicated local environment that you
can't just automatically transplant one
piece of some foreign law and then that
will work and it won't have any
ramifications elsewhere within the
system and that your assumptions about
about how law works in your own country
may be both wrong about your own country
but certainly not really terribly
important for another country but you
still can help so that's the thing how
do you get past the sense of oh my god
I'm just an imperialist Pig and the
answer is you can get past it but that
would take longer if you want to have a
drink I'll tell you all about it
just if I can just add to that I don't
blame you know David and Englander I
actually admire them for being able to
articulate their experience and all that
they took out of it in that critical
sense that that's the biggest
contribution that they leave to my
generation not to engage in the same
mistakes and and as a scholar from
Brazil hopefully based here if tenor is
given to me so my the way I they were I
think up the way I think about it and
how to avoid those those traps is to
precisely invest in creating that
infrastructure that will allow my
students and my colleagues who are
interested in Brazil to have that deeper
engagement and to have that you know to
develop that sense of the complexity and
to be able to look at Brazil and
understand it but also to be you know
vigilant about their biases and and
premises yeah professor drobik I don't
think that it is it was your fault or
any of the Americans to fgv 40 50 years
ago that it was their fault it was
actually the fault of Brazilians
we have this very bad habit of getting
someone else's idea developed for a
different environment and adopting it
let me give you a very simple but very
important example we barbozza
self-entitled the Eagle from Hague
introduced in Brazil American federalism
federalism that was created for a
country where the nation created the
state on a country where the state was
creating the nation did not work we
still have problems hmm more recently we
had this social function of the contract
copied from the Germans but in Germany
was they have a social market economy
which actually functions a little bit
different than our system so we have a
standin see even a scrapping tonality
and the Lieberman and all the others are
very Italians are the Mussolini code we
have a tendency of copying someone
else's ideas not checking the underlying
hypothesis that are valid are the same
or not this is not the forints fault the
foreigners fault it is our fault
well it's both because the ethics of
being a sort of legal exporter if I can
use that have to be have to include
worrying about that tendency and being
sure that you don't contribute to it
that's all I'm saying
so you're absolutely right and that is a
big story about the history of Brazilian
law that we don't have time to go into
I guess I'm we're trying to figure out
what are the ethics of this relationship
and the ethics of this relationship
include really understanding where the
Brazilians are coming from in a context
of equality and if one of the things
that the Brazilians are doing is taking
your advice too soon too easily to
superficially because of these
tendencies it's part of your
responsibility to say wait a minute guys
you know are we going are we going too
fast here so you know this is kind of a
practice issue this is a kind of ethics
of a particular very narrow very small
professional practice and I think we
have to be sensitive on both sides so
yes of course you're right just this
question about the intellectual property
and we are talking about everything
insurance for example or environment
it's the same we are talking about
efficiency and the governance the
bureaucracy of Brazil the problem there
is that we are in the middle of the way
we are not in the pure immature
executive model and we are not in the
pure administrative state model that's
the point so we need to decide in Brazil
what what route we are going to take
that's a problem and the complementary
comment about what Professor cows even
and said about the the more the foreign
models adopted in Brazil the problem in
terms of administrative stage is that
our Constitution of 1989 one was a
carpet by the us further line federalism
and the separation of powers etc etc but
the structure of the deep bureaucracy
the cup was covered by the French model
so yeah very very correct
Bonaparte model yes the pyramid model
very centralizing power in the the
president of the public order it's
different it's not easy to fit the
concept in the u.s. constitutional model
so to accredit French model but figuring
out how to do that should be a challenge
both for Brazilians and Americans so
there's a topic for a research project
by the way there was an effort I don't
know whatever happened to this to it to
bring to Brazil a reform that occurred
in the United States I don't know in the
60s or 70s that was extremely important
for universities which made it easier to
for faculty who developed scientific
investments the developments to to get
the right to the intellectual property
even if the even if the funding had come
from government sources and that led to
a tremendous explosion of startups
around American universities you go to
Wisconsin or Stanford or any of the
major science universities and you'll
see this whole world of startups that
are run by or at least inspired by
professors who develop new ideas often
with federal money until this law reform
in the United States they
benefit from that now they can and I
know that Gaga Arvixe when he was head
of Finetti was trying to get that law
adopted in Brazil but I don't know if it
succeeded did it so have time for a last
question anyone here yeah who's gonna
say a few words about I mean just so I'm
not a lot person I'm a law in society so
my I'm deeply interested in in this
process of importation and exportation
of different legal traditions including
criminal law and and well I have a I
agree with you that this is happening
that Brazilian criminal law is becoming
more and more Americanized especially in
the context of the car wash case what I
think you know as a as a scholar I want
to understand the dimensions of this and
and you know what's what's what's
driving this so a log of that process of
bringing American institutions to
Brazilian law was built within the nclor
the yeah so this was how can I explain
this it was it was a group you know
formal formally defined group of people
that was a panel that was hosted by the
Brazilian Ministry of Justice with
different experts to modernize criminal
law especially with regards to money
laundering and then a lot of people who
were participants of that panel had u.s.
degrees or you know had come to the u.s.
to their al-alem's and all these things
so that I'm understanding I'm interested
in understanding that the channels that
drive this process
perfect yeah yeah and and but also the
the you know the aspects in which this
gets things gets get lost in translation
so for example a judge mogul when he
convicted Tula he he cited two decisions
by US federal appeals court to say that
in corruption in corruption there there
is no need to have the quid pro quo
relationship what's interesting is that
the US Supreme Court defines corruption
as being a quid pro quo in the Macdonald
case you know so I mean he's citing US
jurisprudence when in fact the law of
the land is it goes in a different
direction of which we can be critical
but I mean facts are facts right so so I
would just add the point so that so I
have the sense that because Brazilians
are unwilling or unable to understand
the nature of the problems that the
country is facing because we were unable
to change the institutions which
actually lead to the outcomes that we
don't like then we look for some form of
compensation to at least keep things
going and judges to step in so it seems
to me that part of the legal activism
that is taking place in Brazil is the
second best option at least that's how
we look at it because we are not willing
or able to change the civil the Civil
Procedure the the Criminal Procedure
Code or and so on so the question is
because I I don't know how I can
streamline the Civil Procedure and the
Criminal Procedure in order to finally
get a final decision in a case
bring someone to jail then I allow
someone a judge to you know intervene in
the process or create some exceptions
that would allow someone to go to jail
even before at the end of the process
because I'm not willing or capable of
reform in the structure of universities
that don't seem to be operating that
well in Brazil then I you know create
some form of judicial activism in which
a form of legal decision will make up
for a solution in a specific problem so
and I think this trend to you know bad
our options our future in the hands of
prosecutors and judges even though I am
part of that community is very limited
and very risky at the same time and I
would much rather before if we were
collectively able to look for structural
reforms which would allow the country to
bring to improve the capacity the
effectiveness of public institutions
without having to looking for a shortcut
or for an exception which might seem to
be urgent and necessary in one case but
in the long-term break the capacity of
law the respect of the legitimacy of law
in society so I just would like to end
by thanking everyone who stayed here in
the second panel until this time I'd
like to thank professor Jackson for the
invitation and for being one of the
leaders in putting up his event thank
you stop when the Minister of Education
and I hope you all are back here two
more for the second day of day
[Applause]
[Music]